christian rivera stands charge for the
murder of 20 year old iowa university
student
molly tibbetts rivera's attorney sat
down for an interview with fox's martha
mccallum tonight
where he didn't seem to care that his
client is an illegal immigrant
the united states constitution provides
if you're not a citizen
you still are entitled to the
jurisdictions of the courts
and entitled to equal protection under
the law don't think anyone said he
wasn't what everyone
what people are saying is that he
arrived here illegally from mexico
uh four to seven years ago
that's your rhetoric on it it's not
rhetoric
that's what the immigration officials
are saying their reports indicate
he used a false name to work for an
employer they thought he was somebody
else we know that as well
these are just these are the facts that
are being dug up
in the case martha's exactly right
joining me now with reactions are tom
homan a fox news contributor and the
former acting director of
ice and immigration attorney alan orr
alan
is it is it a legitimate question
or subject for us to discuss if
somebody's here
legally or illegally i think it is if
we're dealing with a matter of
immigration if we're an immigration
court or an immigration proceeding
but i think what the family has said in
this situation
and also what the law sort of bears out
in the way this case is being handled
that the fact that this person is
undocumented is not an essential part of
this
actual criminal activity so therefore
but whether he was
don't you believe if if he was unable to
get here
if he had come legally and lawfully he
may not have ever come here
the fact that he was here and is illegal
he molly would be alive if he weren't in
this country
do you believe that or not believe that
first of all this is an absolute tragedy
and i
offer my condolences to the family and
the possibility of changing what
actually happened
no one can do those circumstances so i'm
not going to play that game what if it's
not a game
it's not a game you see when people are
here illegally and they commit a crime
i really do believe that that crime
wouldn't have been committed because
they wouldn't have been here
is that that is that logical philosophy
major no it's not a logical it's not a
philosophy
it's logic it is not a logical answer no
there are there are endless
possibilities of things that could have
happened so no that is not a lot to
answer
and he would have been in mexico right
we're saying in this particular
occurrence in this specific case
where a young woman going to college
about to enter her junior year
is murdered you're telling me that's not
relevant
i'm i'm i'm uncertain if you're asking
me if the immigration status is relevant
it is not relevant
it is because he wouldn't have been in
this country what is relevant is the
individual and those individual actions
which have been discussed
clearly coming here illegally
ultimately led to her being killed by
this person that's the allegation we'll
see if it's true but that's the
allegation
tom that's uh
that's a fallacy of causation because he
was here for four years with no problem
he worked and you don't know that you
don't we don't know that yet we don't
know that yet
i want to bring in tom tom spent a
lifetime in law enforcement protecting
us and getting rid of some of the most
nefarious criminals that are out there
tom what's your take on this
i think my friend allen's way wrong on
this and you're right look
fact he was in the country illegally
fact if he wasn't here this girl will be
alive today
that's just a fact of the case it's not
a philosophy it's a fact
this this girl is dead today because he
killed her and he was here illegally if
he wouldn't have been here
if we had a border wall if we had real
uh border enforcement maybe he wouldn't
have been here so
it's stone cold fact let me play a
little clip here of a candidate for
the united states senate the person
who's running against
uh ted cruz oh sorry it's not okay we
don't have this clip
but you have a lot of people that are
saying hey uh
we should decriminalize this you know
essentially open borders we want to
abolish ice
alan where do you stand on those two
issues right so
first the abolish ice movement and as
well as the decriminalization of
immigration are totally separate issues
and i want to be very separate but
very clear earlier saying that his
immigration status had nothing to do
with the crime
that and what happened in that
occurrence so the what is not important
or what is going to keep our story i'm
not going to let you get away with that
i'm going to keep arguing
because if you didn't come here
illegally then he wouldn't have
committed this crime
and you think that's a philosophy i
think that's just the fact you know i'm
saying it's a fallacy of causation
you're sort of saying because he was
illegal he
committed the crime which is not the
case
somebody breaks into your home and then
murders you
what do you think would happen if he
didn't break into your home
right so these kind of arguments these
equivocations these straw man arguments
aren't useful to the conversation
we have a dead woman and it is a tragedy
for the family and they've asked that
that her death not be political issues
based on this because that's
the understanding issue tom that it jump
in an individual an individual's actions
does not represent the whole community
of immigrants in this country so
therefore that
i didn't say that but you're no look i'm
not going to let you get away with that
either
there's a difference between immigrants
and illegal immigrants
tom explain the difference look
immigrants are people who really uh
hear illegally illegal alien which is
the term uh in the law books
illegal aliens are here illegally look
bottom line is the comment allen just
made that this family didn't want this
politicized
look illegal immigration has been
political issue for decades is emotional
but look in fact about about two hours
ago i got i got a text a
actual email from don rosenberg and
angel dad from california
who talked about this case and talked
about la editorial where they talked
about politicizing these deaths
don rosenberg reminded me because tom
every one of us us angels families
we want the president to speak about
this we've been speaking all this for a
long time but we never had a voice until
president trump
got to be president he could he created
the voice office victims of immigration
crime at ice so so
here's an angel dad reached out to me
today which is a coincidence we're
having this interview tonight
saying we want a voice we want the
american people to understand the
tragedy
we have we have children that have been
killed by illegal aliens we need to talk
about it
okay there are those of us that believe
in the wall and believe you should lock
down the border
and down in in uh on the southern border
there's this video
which hopefully will come up on the
screen as we're speaking of what was
going on
at a kfc there was a tunnel that was
going into
this kfc which was providing this
conduit this is the kfc
this kind of reminds me of breaking bad
and how they were moving drugs through
this is the tunnel that's moving through
so do you advocate for open borders or
do you think that we need more resources
more funds and more more resources to
lock down that border
particularly on our southern border
allen i don't think anyone is sort of
arguing for open borders and
and the point that you're bringing about
right now i'm glad that we're talking
about the stories because that's exactly
the issue
that ice really should be focused on
these type of issues
rather than separating families and
children at the border
rather than showing up they should be
focused on trying to look for these
major
crimes border patrol separated families
not ice and i support the border patrol
doing that because they would have
stayed with that
the the numbers were already down by 20
percent just for several weeks they did
it
it should have stuck with another 30
days and this problem would have been
solved but the decriminalizing
illegal immigration is going to result
in more illegal immigrants coming to
this country
that's just gentlemen gentlemen thank
you and the reality is if you put up a
wall you're not going to separate
families because they're not going to
get in this country in the first place
well more thank you and i appreciate you
gentlemen being here i really do
appreciate